let's go next to our caller from the
nine one three area code who's calling
today from nine one three
hi David can hear me yeah who's this
this is Brendan I'm calling from Kansas
City Kansas hey Brendan what's going on
I was wondering what your thoughts are
on Bernie Sanders calling himself a
Democratic Socialist when that's clearly
not his real stance on his political
ideology he's obviously a social
democrat you don't want to destroy
capitalism I just I have no idea why he
wants to call himself that I get that he
wants to you know lessen the negativity
of socialism but at the same time that's
just totally wrong I don't totally agree
I don't know why isn't I've got two or
three videos on this Bernie Sanders
should stop saying democratic socialism
and I know that there are the players of
semantic games who will say David
democratic socialism
it just means social democracy now and
that's what Bernie's talking about it's
he's doing himself and the movement a
disservice the policies he's running on
in the policies he's advocating are not
socialist policies they are social
democracy policies and I don't know why
he keeps doing it and I've been saying
for years that he shouldn't be doing it
and I've not gotten a single email from
people that has changed my mind
the one argument people write in with is
David he's just he's changed the words
democratic socialism means social
democracy now and if that's the case I
think it's extremely problematic because
it's just so confusing and it allows the
right to continue to strawman the left
as socialist when almost all of our
policies that are being seriously
discussed are social democracy policies
I think it's a terrible thing and you
should stop yeah I completely agree with
you thanks for taking my call
my pleasure Brendon great to hear from
you from Kansas City hope to hear from
you again